wir müssen noch eine über einen sehr
ernsten Vorfall hier aus Berlin sprechen
es hat vergangene Woche ihren schweren
Unfall gegeben ein Betonmischer hat eine
Radfahrerin umgenietet überfahren und
man hat dann anschließend mit der
Rettungskräften dort im Stau gesteckt
auch weil die Straßen blockiert waren
von sogenannten klimaklebern das heißt
haben diese Menschen mittlerweile auch
ein Menschenleben auf dem Gewissen ihrer
Meinung nach also ich denke mal das
werden die Gerichte entscheiden das weiß
im Moment keiner eine Notärztin hat ja
behauptet was ich ein bisschen
zweifelhaft fand das die einfach so groß
dann dargestellt wurde das
klimaaktivisten keine Schuld haben das
wissen wir noch nicht in Kauf genommen
dass es Opfer gibt wird ja in jedem Fall
wenn man den Verkehr in der Form stört
also das ist schon im Sommer von gesagt
von von vielen Seiten es kann im Stau
können Schwangere sein es können viele
Notfälle da sein also das wird in Kauf
genommen und das halte ich für absolut
super problematisch und deshalb
bin ich auch dagegen ich finde die
Anmaßung dass ein paar wenige Leute
sagen wir wissen jetzt alles und wir
wir stören jetzt einfach die
Gesellschaft und nehmen die Lebensgefahr
in Kaufes spielt gar keine Rolle ob
jetzt diese tote ob das eine Schuldfrage
ist es spielt eigentlich eine Rolle dass
es in Kauf genommen wird und deshalb bin
ich eigentlich gegen diese Methoden und
ich finde sie total anmaßend und es ist
so eine so eine Heiligkeit also dass wir
wissen es und wir bringen es alle
anderen in der Gesellschaft bei und ich
behaupte vor allem es nützt überhaupt
nichts was da geschieht also das für das
Klima ist es nicht in Ordnung für die
Wirtschaft bringt es nicht fürs Land
bringt es nicht was ich gut finde was
ich jetzt gehört habe wenn jemand
Fachmann ist was Klima angeht dann
möchte ich die Expertise die wollen wir
alle gerne hören das finde ich spannend
das kann ich auch anerkennen aber
einfach zu sagen wir sind jetzt
erleuchtet und diese Attitüde ist da und
wir setzen uns hin und stören und wir
nehmen auch Menschen die mir kauft das
ist
kulturrevolutionär mehr noch als
terroristisch und kulturrevolutionär das
muss ich mal dazu sagen das ist ja auch
das Thema meines Buches ist
Informat zu Ton erfunden der die Jugend
in China was dann die 68er nachgemacht
haben aufgemogelt hat für seine Ziele
einfach auf die Straße zu gehen und
Chaos zu machen und zwar mit ganz
ähnlichen
Worthülsen die sie heute noch passieren
Anti Kapitalismus
Weltrettung wir stürmen einfach
Kultur also wir
stürmen die Paläste hat Maul zu tun
gesagt und ich würde nee
das des größten völkermörders
dessen Methoden würde ich nicht
übernehmen das haben die 68er schon
getan jetzt haben wir es mit den Enkeln
zu tun und ich bin absolut für Expertise
ich bin absolut dafür zu hören was die
klima-kritiker sagen was auch die
Wissenschaft sagt und da ist die ganze
Gesellschaft bereit für also es gibt ja
schon von Ursula von der Lage hat die
Notstand ich muss ja noch ganz kurz dann
schon ausgerufen vor zwei Jahren Herr
Habeck habe ich gestern gehört also
unsere ganze Regierung ist ja schon auf
der Seite es bringt also nichts mit
kulturrevolutionären Methoden
Menschenleben zu gefährden und der
ganzen Gesellschaft irgendeine Sache
aufzudrängen die die so nicht hören will
bringt nichts sagt Bettina Röhl und das
riskiert sogar jetzt Menschenleben Herr
moring und trotzdem erleben wir das ja
seit Monaten mittlerweile seit Jahren
sogar so lange engagiert sich ja Herr
Zander schon so aktiv in dieser Bewegung
dort also jeden Tag passiert das auf den
Straßen obwohl jetzt sagt das riskiert
mittlerweile Menschenleben warum
es verändert sich was in Deutschland das
merkt man seit einigen Jahren
wir sehen nicht mit der Lage miteinander
zu diskutieren kann heute im anderen
mehr zu die Gesellschaft läuft
auseinander und die Gewaltspirale nimmt
zu wir sehen das ja wir haben vor ein
paar Jahren im Strafgesetzbuch eine
neuen Tatbestand eingeführt Gefährdung
von berufshelfern weil wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen konnten vorher dass wir
Rettungssanitäter Feuerwehrleute im
Einsatz sind dass die angegriffen werden
und die zu schützen haben wir das
Strafgesetz an der Stelle erweitert und
jetzt diskutieren wir wieder über neue
Normen die man wirklich machen müssen
weil wir sehen dass die Eskalation die
Mittel aggressiver werden das anketten
ist dahin genommen und wenn es eine
Strafe gibt folgt die auf dem Fuße das
ist so aber jetzt erleben wir ja das
möglicherweise gar nicht auf dem Fuß
hätte das sagen sie so das folgt dir gar
nicht auf dem Fuß dann können wir gerade
machen wann war ihr Prozess nach der
Tatort am Verkehrsminister zwei Jahre
später drei Jahre später
genau die Frage auf welcher Perspektive
Moment das sieht zunächst würde ich mal
sagen jeder Protest das kommt aus
unserer Freiheit in der Demokratie ist
zunächst legitim das gehört zu unseren
Freiheitsrecht natürlich besser kämpft
haben dass wir demonstrieren dürfen dass
unsere Meinung sagen dürfen dass wir uns
versammeln dürfen aber unsere
Freiheitsrechte sind dort begrenzt wo
wir andere Freiheitsrechte von anderen
wieder begrenzen und dass der Staat dann
da das zu ordnen unsere Regeln durch
Gesetze erleben gerade das genau diese
gesetzliche gebrochen werden durch genau
diese das ist Bewegung eine Frage
diskutieren wir gleich weiter Hermann
gewaltfrei das Stichwort viel gerade von
Herrn Zander wir sind Gewalt ist das so
Ihrem Empfinden ihren Beobachtungen nach
nein das ist es eben leider nicht denn
es wird hier natürlich schon Gewalt
ausgeübt ist werden Menschen genötigt
sie können eben nicht die Straßen
benutzen diese benutzen wollen es hat
Hausfriedensbruch stattgefunden es wurde
in Häuser anderer Menschen eingedrungen
und auch auf der nachdrücklich bitten
das Haus nicht wieder verlassen wir
haben bei BMW festgestellt auch
Hausfriedensbruch die Firma BMW sagt an
den Fahrzeugen dort in der
Ausstellungshalle in der BMW Welt ist
das wird im Moment noch überprüft ein
Schaden zwischen 100.000 und einer
Millionen Euro entstanden wer sich so
aufführt wer derartig vorgeht der kann
doch nicht davon sprechen dass er
gewaltfrei unterwegs ist sondern da wird
in der Tat brutale Gewalt verübt die
überwiegend noch gegen Sachen aber wir
wissen leider aus der Erfahrung in der
Vergangenheit auch wer anfängt brutal
gegen Sachen Gewalt zu verüben das ist
ja auch so wenn einer da in die Museen
stürmt und
wertvolle Bilder beschädigt da ist die
Gefahr immer groß dass das irgendwann
auch in Gewalt gegen Menschen
unmittelbar umschlägt das Schuld das ist
Nötigung das ist ein Stück weit
Erpressung wenn man diejenigen die es
eilig haben zur Arbeit fahren wollen
morgens immer und immer wieder dazu
zwingt im Stau zu stehen sich dadurch
politische Dinge zu erpressen oder
wollen sie widersprechen natürlich ist
das Nötigung und man sollte diesen
Burschen einsperren das ist völlig in
Ordnung weil die Deutschen Gefängnisse
die sind ja geheizt im Winter in den
deutschen Gefängnissen geht es einem
recht gut man kann auch sein Doktortitel
noch mal
überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht dies
wird viel zu hoch gehängt von diesem
Sheriff aus Bayern das ist eine ganz
harmlose Geschichte was hier stattfindet
und auch von ihnen das ist auch für Sie
da dass sie diesen einen Unfall daher
zaubern nein das ist eine Zahl
überhaupt nicht dass Maßstab wird
vollkommen verrückt denken Sie mal daran
was zur selben Minute im Mittelmeer an
toten dort entstehen und dass diese
braven Kinder endlich aufgewacht sind
doch nicht der Wohlstandsgesellschaft
die Kinder all dieser Spieße die über
viele Jahrzehnte zugeguckt haben wie
sich die Welt veränderte wir sind
Spieler gemacht
hat das natürlich ein spießer-sendung
Generation selbst erschaffen
das ist ja immer das begriffliche die
einen agieren mit Begriffen wie Klima ja
was überhaupt nicht was Klima ist das
kann die nächsten 50 Jahre jetzt 30
Jahre jetzt festgelegt warum das 100 das
sind in der in der Erdgeschichte
Sekundenbruchteile und ich meine dieses
ewig des apothekische zu erklären was
was ich verändert ihr wisst gar nichts
wie es zum Beispiel dass Sie dass die
dass die Umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit der
Erde leicht zunimmt was das auslöst wir
wissen es nicht wir sitzen in einem
ungeheueren Universum und tun so als
würde man irgendwas Regeln können wir
auch diese co2-geschichte na gut daneben
ist Methan was in meinem Namen
sie haben alle die Generation die Eltern
Generation viel zu lange zugeguckt sie
haben sie ausprobieren
das war der Vorwurf von der
Probleme die 60er Jahre wo wir alle
schon wussten also ich habe in seiner
Zeit im alten simpel hier mein Freund
Hermann ne da waren Sina in der Schule
nein das ist ja nicht
persönlich
Fridericianum Musik Museum habe ich
schon Gymnasium nein damals habe ich zu
Willy Brandt am Tisch im alten simpel
gesagt 1969 eines Tages wird die Umwelt
die Welt verändern und das Thema wird
uns alle bestimmen da rief mein Freund
heute ebke über den Tisch halt du deine
Mund geh lieber zu CSU wir wollen
Kanzler und so wurden sie Kanzler aber
da kommt jetzt etwas mein Freund zum zum
sagen wenn man die Wahrheit sagt wird
man nicht Kanzler das wissen wir von den
derzeitig amtierenden
in diesem Land Zander einmal Ring nach
Luft und will einmal aufhören Hermann
Antworten der ihm massiv Erpressung
Nötigung vorgeworfen hat ja ich will nur
einmal darauf eingehen wollen als
wissenschaftlich auch Doktor Zander
nennen wenn Sie gerne wollen weil ich
bin ja auch als Wissenschaftler und zwar
die Wissenschaft waren seit Jahrzehnten
und wenn die Politik nicht in der Lage
ist darauf einzugehen und richtige
Mittel zu ergreifen dann sage ich als
Wissenschaftler das ist richtig was die
Menschen dort machen und nicht nur ich
als Wissenschaftler andere
Wissenschaftler auch in Süddeutschland
dann sagen sie wenn das nicht richtig
läuft da oben dann ist Demokratie für
mich nichts Demokratie ist das
Wichtigste was wir haben nur die wird
gerade unter wandert durch Lobbyismus in
der Politik wie kann es zum Beispiel
sein das wie kann es zum Beispiel sein
dass die Deutsche Bank in dem letzten
Jahr über 1,1 Milliarden Euro Gewinn
gemacht hat aber Menschen gerade nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Stromrechnung
unterschreiben
die die über das System zu sprechen weil
ich habe sie gefragt ob sie an die
Demokratie glauben und sie haben gesagt
eigentlich ist das das Beste was wir
haben aber es funktioniert nicht das
heißt wollen Sie ein anderes System nein
die Demokratie ist das was wir brauchen
wir brauchen mehr Demokratie und auch
die Demokratie innerhalb der Demokratie
habe ich persönlich alle möglichen
Mittel der Demonstration ausgeschöpft
ich habe auch in der Wissenschaft viele
Mittel ausgeschöpft glauben Sie mir wenn
man mir nicht zuhört und meinen ganzen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann haben wir
ein Problem denn wenn die Welt zwei oder
drei Grad wärmer wird was passiert denn
dann wenn dann ist es nicht so dass ein
paar Bäume sterben dann werden es massiv
leiten
und zu der Radikalität möchte kurz sagen
das was jetzt als radikal geframt wird
das sind
Straftaten allerdings die Nötigung die
dann zutrifft der Umweg der Stau ist
finden so viel Staus in Deutschland
jedes Jahr statt sie konnten
ihre einzelne tat das stimmt doch gar
nicht die Radikalität die uns in Zukunft
erwartet ist viel größer auch das
rechtfertige das nicht aber das ist
genau ihr Staatsverständnis was ist
schwierig ist sie sagen sie haben eine
legitimes Ziel und dieses legitime Ziel
rechtfertigt auch Gewalttaten und
Straftaten genau das stimmt eben nicht
weil keine auch kein gutes Ziel
rechtfertigt dem Gesetzesbruch und das
genau der Unterschied den haben wir oft
bei links und rechts Debatten es ist
auch so das linke sagen ihre ihre Taten
sind gerechtfertigt weil sie von gutes
Ziel eintreten und Nazis vom Grunde her
sowieso nicht da kann man lange darüber
streiten was da richtig ist aber auch
bei ihnen habe ich es mehrmals in
Diskussion gehört dass sie sagen wir
haben ein wichtiges Ziel das Klima die
Klimakatastrophe droht und deshalb ist
meine Tat gerechtfertigt damit stellen
sie ja den Staat an sich in Frage damit
stellen sie die Demokratie in Frage und
damit tragen sie genau dazu bei was ich
vorhin beschrieben habe dass die Leute
unsere Demokratie nicht mehr zutrauen im
Osten mittlerweile nur noch 38 Prozent
das kommt auch durch solche Taten weil
sie den Start in Frage stellen die
genauen Frage stellen und sagen sie
wissen es besser wie es geht und damit
bringen sie unsere Zusammenhalt
durcheinander sie haben gerade gehört
was Herr Dr Zander auf sie gerade
geantwortet hatte Hermann das heißt mit
dem müssen sie sich ja sozusagen wenn es
auch nicht ganz hier Bundesland ist
weiter rumschlagen wie gehen Sie mit dem
um der ganz offen sagt ich glaube nicht
an das was ihr beschließt glaubt nicht
an das was ihr an Politik macht ich
werde andere Wege gehen
ich bin was die Sache des Klimaschutzes
zusammen betrifft anderer Meinung als
Herr Thoma das ist völlig klar aber das
ist jetzt hier heute denke ich nicht
meine Hauptjob zu sagen was müssen wir
alles für den Klimaschutz tun wollen
da geht es darum dass wir geordnete
Spielregeln in unserem Land haben müssen
weil es viele Leute gibt da schließe ich
gerne das was Mike Mohring gerade gesagt
hat die sagen ich habe meine Überzeugung
und für die Kämpfe ich dafür leben wir
in der Demokratie dafür haben wir
Meinungsfreiheit dafür haben wir
Versammlungsfreiheit aber würde jeder
dafür seine Überzeugungen auf die Straße
gehen und versuchen andere Menschen
davon zu erzeugen das Problem bei Herrn
weil der Entschuldigung
geil soll ich nach Süddeutschland kommen
nicht darum dass ich die Leute
einsperren will sondern es geht darum es
geht darum dass der Herr Zander es
bisher nicht geschafft hat eine Mehrheit
der Menschen in Deutschland von seinen
Überzeugungen sein
in Deutschland bringt nicht so wer
Zander und das Problem das Problem dass
Herr Zander jetzt sagt weil er es nicht
geschafft hat mit seiner Argumentation
und seinen Demonstrationen die Menschen
zu überzeugen deswegen meinte ich jetzt
Gewalt gerechtfertigt und wenn wir das
Anfangen in unserem Staat dass jeder der
meint dass er mit demokratischen Mitteln
keine Mehrheit erreichen kann deswegen
Gewalt anwenden kann dann ist dieser
Staat